– Hey!
– Huhu!
– Ich hab grad mein Auto verkauft.
– Sehr gut!
Du kannst mal Nicos Bewerbung für
die Schauspielschule lesen.
Er will’s jetzt doch versuchen.
– Was? Wozu das denn?
– Wozu? Du bist gut!
Es ist wichtig, dass alles korrekt ist.
– Also!
Name, Adresse, Telefonnummer,
Geburtsdatum, Geburtsort,
Nationalität: Spanier.
Das ist soweit in Ordnung.
Hm … Schulausbildung ist hier …
Sprachkenntnisse, Computerkenntnisse –
okay, Interessen und Fähigkeiten …
Seit wann interessierst du dich
denn für modernes Theater?
Das hast du selbst geschrieben?
– Ja!
– Also, der Lebenslauf ist bis auf ein paar
kleine Rechtschreibfehler
so schon in Ordnung.
Ich würd vorschlagen, wir schauen
uns mal dein Motivationsschreiben an.
– Na los, fangen wir an.
– Also hier können wir auf jeden Fall noch
’n paar Formulierungen ändern.
Dein Motivationsschreiben muss
überzeugender sein.
Mach es persönlich.
Warum willst du auf diese Schule
und warum bist du der Richtige dafür?
Du interessierst dich doch
für das Studium, oder?
– Klar!
Danke, Pepe. Bis morgen.
– Gern, bis später.
Da ist noch was.
Hier: die Struktur deiner Website.
Ich hab ’n paar kurze Texte
geschrieben und …
Ist nur ’n erster Entwurf,
aber ... schau einfach mal rein.
– Werd ich machen. Danke.
– Bis später, Yara.
– Bis dann.